AARON HIRSH: My goal in
the next 40 minutes or so
will be to get to the
deeper ideas in the book,
"Telling Our Way to the Sea."
And those are ideas not
only about ecology but also
about storytelling.
So I'll be dipping
into the book now
and then to read a
little bit to you.
And that's actually
how I'd like to start.
Let me just plunge right in.
"A school of needlefish
parts to stream around me,
and I find myself momentarily
among the silver traces
of a comet shower.
I move to join them, but
they accelerate and dissolve
into open water, leaving me to
stare at the luminous, molten
mirror that is the underside
of the ocean surface.
Veronica taps my arm-- a signal
that says both, look at that
and be right back-- as she slips
from the roiled layer of silver
and descends swiftly, like
a being born underwater.
Her skindiver's fins form
a single, broad fluke
which propels her
neoprene form sinuously
toward the rocky bottom.
Bright bubbles escaping
her snorkel wobble urgently
back to the air above.
A thousand times I have
seen her descend like this.
Yet still, I find myself
wondering if, this time,
she might go too deep
or stay too long.
Here, mercifully, the sea
floor is only 20 feet down,
a depth at which the
plunging chutes of sunlight
are just converging to
their vanishing point.
As she approaches
the rocks, Veronica
twists, glides to a supine
and weightless pause,
and gazes up at the students
who float beside me here
at the surface.
She seems to be pointing at
something on the sea floor.
Allie, the student to my
right, turns to look at me.
Inside the partial
shade of her dive mask,
her eyes are hard to read.
They look puzzled,
a little concerned.
She's probably
just wondering why
Veronica wants
them to notice what
appears to be a mud-brown
lump of sea muck.
Though it also seems possible
that Allie has already
perceived Veronica's
tendencies underwater,
the strange private gravity
that seems to draw her to depth,
and she is now asking
in her gentle way
whether something should perhaps
be done to bring Veronica back
to the surface.
I take several long breaths,
saturating my blood with oxygen
and preparing to dive.
But just as I draw my
last deep dose of air,
Veronica finally relents.
She places her hand gently
around the nondescript mound
and pulls it from
the rocks, holding it
as one might hold a
soft loaf of bread.
Arriving among us,
Veronica holds out her hand
upon which rests
her inert quarry.
What was mud-colored
below is now,
in this bright, shallow
water, more of a yellow ochre,
and it is studded with pale
tubercles that are almost
the color of lemon drops.
The skin, stretched taut
over the knobby body,
appears thin and mucosal,
making this thing look terribly
exposed, like a bodily organ
drawn by the hand of a surgeon
into the sudden brightness
of the operating theater.
The students-- there are
five of them here-- draw in
around Veronica's
palm, peering intently
through their panes
of tempered glass.
They seem transfixed, certain
that Veronica's plunge must
have been for
something thrilling.
The lump trembles, inches
forward along Veronica's palm.
Suddenly it is less
vegetable than animal,
and the students pull
back apprehensively.
But as the circle of
masks starts to widen,
Veronica's free hand
catches Allie by the wrist.
Veronica is wise, I
think, to choose Allie,
because there are others who
might not be so trusting.
Carefully, she
opens Allie's palm
and holds it beside her own.
As the knobby creature slides
from one hand to the other,
Allie's eyes widen,
and she speaks
into her snorkel, an
incomprehensible but richly
expressive string of syllables.
For a moment, she seems frozen.
But even in her
astonishment, she
looks to the other students.
She takes the hand of the
young man floating beside her,
opens his palm, and
holds it next to her own.
The animal slides
over obligingly.
And as it does, Cameron
explores the creature's back
with his other hand.
Cameron's hands look
muscular, well worn,
and they sometimes
move in unusual ways.
The fingers seem to
explore independently,
executing many minor adjustments
as if they were navigating
the neck of a string instrument.
These hands have learned to
perceive more than other hands
because Cameron cannot see.
He is blind.
And as his fingers creep
across the animal's back,
investigating, it
becomes clear that they
are following a pattern.
The yellow warts,
which at first seemed
to be scattered more
or less randomly,
are in fact arranged, loosely
but nonetheless perceptibly,
into two rows.
I've never noticed
this rough regularity.
But now that I see it, I
suspect it might be meaningful.
I suspect, in fact, that
those two haphazard rows are
clues to a deep connection,
an invisible but very real
threat that links the ugly
animal on Cameron's hand
to far more beautiful creatures
we've seen this morning.
Just moments before
her plunge, Veronica
pointed us to a sun star,
Heliaster kubiniji, a pink
and green starfish in
the unmistakable shape
of a sunflower.
And before that, we all
hovered in admiration
over the crown sea
urchin, Centrostephanus
coronatus, which is a sphere
of long and slender spines,
each one perfectly black but
for the occasional sharp wave
of blue light that
races from tip to base.
To describe these scattered
pulses to Cameron,
Allie said it looked
"like an alien's brain."
So the connection that
those little bumps
on the back of the animal that
Cameron discovered revealed
was membership in the
phylum Echinodermata.
Now what that really means is
that that little ugly animal
and those more beautiful
creatures we'd seen earlier
that day on the dive
are all descended
from a single species, a single
ur-echinoderm, you could say,
that inhabited the oceans
520 million years ago.
That ur-echinoderm,
in its time on Earth,
hit upon some
terrific inventions,
evolutionary
innovations, basically.
And those inventions
were passed down
to the various animals
that now belong
to this group, Echinodermata.
The tubercles on the animal's
back bespeak one of those.
But another one,
and what Cameron
wanted to show them
now, is something
called mutable
connective tissue.
And I need to tell you how
mutable connective tissue works
so that you understand the
next part of the story.
Mutable connective
tissue, it's really
just collagen, the
stuff that makes up
the cartilage in your knees
and the discs in your spine
and that makes your
nose kind of stiff.
But whereas our collagen stays
relatively hard all the time,
echinoderms have
an amazing ability
to change the nature
of their collagen.
Collagen is a polymer,
meaning it's built up
of many, many copies of the
same little molecule that
link together.
You can imagine twist ties
that you wind together
into something like a
suspension bridge cable.
That's what a collagen fiber is.
It's basically twist ties wound
into a suspension bridge cable.
Now what echinoderms can
do, thanks to little cells
embedded in their collagen,
is those little cells release
a compound, and it causes
the suspension bridge cable
to immediately fall apart
into billions of twist ties.
At the level of the animal,
that looks like something
with it is hard, like
billiard ball hard one moment,
going pudding soft.
It basically liquefies itself.
More amazingly, what
the animal can do
is those cells secrete an
antidote to the first compound.
The twist ties then
quickly rewind themselves
into the suspension
bridge cable.
And that animal that
was liquefying itself
becomes billiard ball hard.
This is what Veronica, who
brought the cucumber up
to the surface, wanted
to show the students.
Now by the time she
decided to demonstrate
the properties mutable
connective tissue,
the animal had been
passed around the students
and was now resting on the
hands of a student named Anoop.
And Anoop was game, but he
wasn't quite as comfortable
in the water as all
the other students.
So he was holding
this creature and just
barely managing to keep
his chin above water
at the moment the Veronica
decides that she's
going to show us what mutable
connective tissue can do.
"At the moment, the
most pressing mystery
is why Veronica would
take Anoop, of all people,
as her volunteer
for a magic trick
with mutable connective tissue.
Given that we will try this only
once in our two-week course,
I don't see why she
would make Anoop
the one whose nerves
will be tested.
Does she think his
excitability will
enhance the shock
of transformation?
Or has she really
put him on my watch,
allowing herself to
forget her own warnings?
In any case, when she places
her snorkel in her mouth
and puts her face in
the water, all of us
follow suit, except Anoop.
With the animal stranded
on his trembling hands,
he is unable to
replace his snorkel
and is left alone above
water while everyone
watches his hands below.
Through my
half-submerged mask, I
keep a watchful eye
on Anoop's face.
At first he looks
somewhat resigned,
like a surgical patient
separated from the doctor's
work by a curtain
across his chest.
But a second later, he whips
his head suddenly to the side,
trying to catch his snorkel's
mouthpiece with his teeth.
He makes three such
lunges, each of them
unsuccessful, before he gives
up, takes a deep breath,
and submerges his face, just
in time to see Veronica's index
finger pressing on
the animal's back.
The creature
compresses instantly,
but Anoop holds steady.
Veronica places Cameron's
hand on the frozen animal,
and the other
students, too, feel
the hardness of
cross-linked collagen.
As Anoop watches their hands
reaching in to investigate,
his cheeks begin to
swell with the pressure
of unexhaled breath.
And just when it appears
they might burst open,
admitting a gasp of seawater,
Allie reaches across our circle
and places Anoop's
snorkel in his mouth.
Through his glinting
mask, he seems
to look gratefully at her.
Veronica begins to
rub the animal's back,
and at first, it
appears to relax.
But then something goes wrong.
The creature skips
liquefaction and moves
straight to more
drastic measures,
the last line of defense.
Because an echinoderm's
nervous system speaks directly
to those special cells embedded
in the collagen matrix,
telling them when to release
their potent catalyst
of change, the animal
can freeze or liquefy
whichever piece of
tissue it needs to.
This is how a brittle
star caught by the arm
can throw off the entire
limb, leaving it behind
like the detached
tail of a lizard.
It simply liquefies the
narrow segment of tissue
that connects the arm
to the central disk.
And when a cucumber
is under attack,
it resorts to an even
more radical tactic.
It swiftly disassembles
the collagen cables
that holds its organs, violently
contracts its entire body wall,
and shoots its
viscera out its anus.
One can imagine that even the
most menacing predator might
be taken aback by such a move.
And even if it weren't,
it might at least
be tricked into pursuing the
evacuated innards instead
of the now hollow cucumber.
Taking a bite of
floating viscera,
the predator would quickly
learn that the animal
is laced with a powerful toxin.
The hollowed cucumber,
meanwhile, would have moved on
and would later regenerate from
stem cells and its empty body
cavity a complete set
of internal organs.
But if evisceration might
distract a menacing predator,
just think what it
could do to Anoop.
When the dark purple organs
explode from the animal's
posterior, he
startles and flails,
attempting to back away quickly.
The guts purl and twist
in his turbulence,
forming a kinetic design of
dark ribbons, diffusing colors,
and loose, round forms at
the center of our circle.
From the bottom of
this turning mobile,
the cucumber body sinks
toward the sea floor."
So later that same
day, I was sitting
on the terrace of the
Vermilion Sea Field Station.
And those same
five students were
gathered at the other
edge of the terrace,
and they were reliving their
moment with the cucumber.
Anoop was reenacting
the whole thing,
and they were all laughing.
In a moment in which
they fell silent,
Cameron, the blind young
man, turned in my direction
and yelled, hey, why doesn't
something just eat that thing?
And I didn't know how
he knew I was there,
but I picked up my chair and
walked over and sat with them.
And for the next
two hours or so,
we just talked about
the sea cucumber.
We talked first about
holothurin, that toxin
that I mentioned,
lacing the animal
and how it's now serving as a
model for chemotherapy drugs.
And we talked about the East
Asian market for cucumber.
There's a large fishery
for cucumbers, actually.
And then eventually,
the cucumber
led us into pretty deep
evolutionary questions
about recapitulation, the
idea that the development
of an individual
organism recapitulates
the forms of that organism's
ancestor through time,
from ancient ancestor
to present animal.
So without getting into
any of those conversations,
I want to take a
step back and observe
what was happening there,
because that's really
what the book is about.
What was happening
there, I think,
is that we had taken an
animal as the starting
point for storytelling.
And we allowed ourselves
to be digressive.
We talked about its poisons.
We talked about its markets.
We talked about its
evolution and its ecology.
And at the end of that
long conversation,
there was another pause
in which Cameron summed up
what had happened in
that conversation.
He was a surfer.
He was from Santa Barbara,
so he talked like a surfer.
And he said in
that moment, do you
realize that this entire
gnarly conversation started
with that knobby thing
that puked on Anoop?
And it sounds funny,
but it's stuck with me.
And the reason it
stuck with me is
that it struck me
as the solution
to a problem, the answer
to a question that
has occurred to me often
in many different places,
certainly in Bahia
de los Angeles.
Here's the question.
Why are we such dismal
stewards of the natural world?
Why is it that place after
place, sea after sea,
landscape after landscape,
we over-fish the sea,
deforest the
landscape to an extent
that it's very difficult
to bring it back?
What is it about
us that makes us
so bad at taking care
of the natural world?
And I think there
were two deeper
answers to this question.
And Cameron's funny line
is a part of a solution.
The first answer,
I think, is that we
have a problem of memory.
We actually don't remember what
those seas or landscapes looked
like long ago.
And lacking a vivid
memory of their grandeur,
we also are without a
motivation to restore them
to their former state.
I can illustrate
this with the sea
cucumber, this
problem of memory.
The first time I was in
the Sea of Cortez, Veronica
brought the same animal, a sea
cucumber, up for us to look at.
And I'd never seen
a big one before.
I'd been diving a lot but
never seen this exotic animal.
And so I took it as a sign
of the bay's richness.
I suspected, ah, I've
never seen this thing
before anywhere else.
That must mean that this
bay, where we are right now,
is relatively untouched.
In fact, as I learned
later, I could have taken it
as a testament to the extent to
which the bay has been scoured.
Veronica explained that
the year before, a couple
years before, she'd been
sitting on that same terrace
and had watched as boat after
boat returned across the bay,
piled high with
brown sea cucumbers.
And that one season
of extraction
changed the Bay of LA from a
place where sea cucumbers could
be found about one every square
meter or so to a place where
finding one was a special
occasion, an occasion
to gather the students and talk
about this strange creature.
The point is that I
misread that moment.
Lacking a memory of a bay
rich with sea cucumbers,
it didn't occur to me that
in fact what I was seeing
was a small remnant of
what was once there.
And you could say
that's because I'm not
local to Bahia de los
Angeles, which I'm not.
But also, there's
an entire generation
of inhabitants of Bahia do Los
Angeles who also have never
seen a rocky reef rich
with sea cucumbers.
For them, too, this is
the state of nature.
And in fact, for
each generation,
there is a new state of nature.
Each of us takes the wildest
place we've ever seen
and thinks of it as wilderness.
The place we saw in our
childhood or the place
we saw on that
nature documentary,
we think, ah, now
that is really nature.
But we're wrong.
That's not really nature.
In fact, nature was something
much richer than that.
Fisheries managers refer to the
problem of a shifting baseline,
which means that each
generation of fishery manager
has his own baseline expectation
of what the sea can yield.
But because each generation
inherits a slightly
degraded sea,
there's this process
of generational decay
in our idea of the sea.
You could also say, well, maybe
it's just because that sea
cucumber is an
ugly little thing,
and who's really going
to notice its absence?
But when I started looking
into this as a problem,
it was clear that
the same phenomenon
of drifting expectations
had occurred
with every other charismatic
creature I could find.
Around the Sea of
Cortez, there's
a correlation between the age
of a fisherman and his estimate
of how large a fish can grow for
any number of species of fish.
So for example, if you ask
a 70-year-old fisherman,
how big does a yellow tail get?
The answer is, 4
and 1/2, 5 feet.
If you ask a
30-year-old fisherman,
the answer is 3 and 1/2, 4 feet.
And it's not, what's the
biggest one you've ever seen?
It's, how big can they get?
There's a different idea
of what the sea can do.
Or another example-- the word
mantarraya Older fishermen
use the word mantarraya to
refer to Manta birostris, which
is an animal that grows
to about 25 feet across.
You know what a
manta ray looks like.
It's that thing with
the big black wings
and the long stingray tail.
Mantarraya, to an older
fisherman, is that animal,
Manta birostris.
To a younger person in
Bahia de los Angeles,
mantarraya actually refers to
a different set of species,
because they've never
seen Manta birostris.
They've seen much
smaller species
that are about 4
or 5 feet across,
members of the genus Mobula.
For them, mantarraya means that.
The older fisherman
has a different word
for that thing,
the smaller thing.
But that word isn't used
by the younger people.
So even the language
has changed.
The word mantarraya now
signifies something smaller
than what it used to signify.
It's not always something
disappearing or shrinking.
Sometimes it's actually
something arriving.
So the biggest fishery
in the Sea of Cortez
right now is the Humboldt squid.
It's about a 4-foot
animal that looks
like the calamari you
eat, but it's huge.
And that animal didn't show
up in the Sea of Cortez
until about 1974,
when fishermen removed
so many large fish,
predatory fish like tuna,
yellowtail-- which is what you
think of as hamachi-- mackerel,
they took out so many of
those that the Humboldt squid
moved in as the new
dominant predator.
And there it has
stayed ever since.
So for anyone under the age of
30 or 40 in the Sea of Cortez,
the sea of Cortez is
full of Humboldt squid.
They don't remember
a Sea of Cortez
that was instead
full of large fish.
So why did Cameron's
line strike me
as a solution to this problem?
When you take a
creature as the starting
point for your
storytelling and you
allow yourself to be
digressive, you nearly
automatically begin
to reconstruct
a vision of what the
ecosystem once was.
The reason it happens is
that the stories essentially
serve to connect one
creature to another.
And as you follow
them outwards, you
come to something that's now
missing in the Sea of Cortez.
There's an interesting
metaphor for this,
these kind of
connections, for which I'd
like to turn to Henry
David Thoreau, actually.
So this is Thoreau.
"I take infinite pains to
know all the phenomenon
of the spring, thinking that
I have here the entire poem.
And then, to my
chagrin, I hear that it
is but an imperfect copy
that I possess and have read,
that my ancestors
had torn out many
of the first leaves
and grandest passages
and mutilated it in many places.
I should not like to think
that some demi-god had come
before me and picked out
some of the best stars.
I wish to know an entire
heaven and an entire earth."
I'm going to just keep
reading for a moment.
"Over the past 10
years on the bay,
I have tried to gather up
scraps torn from the poem.
I've collected them from
Veronica; from her mentor,
Lane; from the
turtle man, Antonio;
from the wandering drama critic,
Krutch; and from many others.
With my hands full of
ragged bits and scraps,
I might be inclined to
believe that the bay has been
more severely rifled,
more drastically abridged
than other places
I've lived or visited.
But the opposite is true.
In the bay, many passages
were lost so recently
that people I knew
could recite them.
And the poem, pared and
slashed though it was,
remain sufficiently coherent
to betray certain gaps.
In other places I've been,
so much was lost and lost
so long ago that
there are hardly
reminders of the
poem's former content.
Who on the Eastern
seaboard is struck
by the absence of migrating gray
whales or nesting sea turtles
or playful and clever sea
mink or river-frothing runs
of salmon and eel?
Yet they were all there and
there in great abundance.
We live amid the
wreckage, yet we hardly
notice that something
has changed."
When we were sitting
there on the terrace,
talking about the
sea cucumber, we
were reciting the extended
poem of Isostichopus fuscus,
the brown sea cucumber.
And when you do that, you follow
those digressive tales and run
into the tears in the fabric,
the ecological fabric.
Or to take Thoreau's
metaphor, imagine
you're looking at the sky, and
you see the Big Dipper there.
But one star is missing.
You notice.
If you're looking
at the Big Dipper,
and that star that's at the
front of the little ladle
is gone, you're going to notice.
You wouldn't notice if any other
star was taken out of the sky,
because you don't have the shape
to give you an expectation.
Stories about animals
are like that.
You follow them from
one species to another
to another to another.
And when you come to a
place where one should be,
you notice that it's missing.
I'll give you an example.
So that manta ray,
when I started
looking in the history
of the manta ray
in Bahia de los
Angeles, the first place
I found records was in writings
from the pearl industry.
In the 16th and
17th century, there
was a thriving pearl industry
in the Sea of Cortez.
They thought that the manta ray
was the most dangerous predator
of pearl divers.
They thought that manta rays
would hover above the diver,
and when the diver
came up, he would
envelop them and devour him.
The manta ray actually
eats plankton.
It's a filter feeder.
So it was a strange tale
that they'd come up with.
But nonetheless, whenever
they saw one, they killed it.
Reading this tale, the
first thing you think
is, hmm, strange idea.
The second thing you
think is, pearl industry?
There's no pearl industry
in the Sea of Cortez.
But in fact, the entire
coastline of the Sea of Cortez
was formerly covered in
thick reefs of pearl oysters.
Now there are lovely
beaches and rocky reefs
because the pearl oysters
have all been removed
and were removed by
about 1750 or so.
So there's no memory of them.
But if you start thinking
about the manta ray
and what happened
to it, you run into
a couple different exotic
species of pearl oyster--
the rainbow pearl oyster,
the black pearl oyster.
So continuing forward
with the manta ray,
after the pearl
industry collapsed,
the main danger to the
manta ray were fishing boats
because fishing boats,
if they saw one,
they'd try to kill
a 25-foot animal
because it was a
lot of free meat.
They'd harpoon it.
But a harpoon, what is a fishing
boat doing with a harpoon?
Fishing boats today
in the Sea of Cortez
have small fish traps
and fine-gauge gill nets.
Fishing boats carried
harpoons because they
were looking for
turtles, sea turtles.
There were four
species of sea turtle.
You never see them anymore
in the Sea of Cortez.
They're all four
endangered species.
Now the greatest threat
for the manta ray
are the drift nets which
are placed for billfish
like marlin, but
they also take out
several different
species of shark.
So you see how you can
start with one animal
and tell its stories,
and inevitably, you
encounter the other things
that are gone-- the pearl
oysters, the four species
of sea turtles, the sharks.
The reason this happens,
for you network theorists,
is that the ecosystem
is highly connective.
It's a small world
topology, essentially.
When you start talking
about one creature,
the ecological or
historical relationships
are so reticulate that
they're going to lead you out
across the entire network.
And that's why the
process of storytelling
restores to you
almost inevitably
a sense of what
the sea once was.
And the hope, of course, is that
if that vision is compelling,
we'll find a new motivation
for making our way back there.
Of course, the process can also
kindle some dismay and even
despair.
But here, too, I think Cameron's
observation can help us
because what are we doing
when we're situating
an animal in its network, in its
ecological or historical web?
We're really finding the
meaning of that animal.
We're recovering a sense of that
creature's meaning and value,
because what is meaning but
a connection between one
entity and many others?
What's meaning in a language?
What's the meaning of a word?
It's the connection, the
relationships between that word
and many other words.
Or what's meaning
in a human life?
It's the connections
between an individual
and larger entities
or other individuals.
In the same way, the meaning
or value of a creature
is apparent when you situate it
in its ecological or historical
context.
A brown sea cucumber sitting
on the bottom of the ocean
is not an obviously valuable
or meaningful entity.
But when it comes
to the surface,
and you start talking about the
various ways in which it makes
sense, the various functions
it serves, the ways it works,
suddenly it becomes a
really valuable creature.
And I think that
process can help
us reconcile two
visions of nature that
have been in play here.
On the one hand, the nature that
has grandeur, the 25-foot manta
ray, the sea turtles.
On the other hand,
the clear sense
that this is a
degraded natural world.
How do we hold those together?
One way we can
hold them together
is through this process
of digressive storytelling
which compels us to face nature
as we contend with it today
but allows us to hold in mind,
at the same time, a sense
of what the natural
world could be.
And I want to close
with a reading that
speaks to that difficulty.
"One evening, I thought
I'd search the internet
for reports of
mantas in the bay.
I entered the words manta
ray, Bahia de los Angeles.
And when I pressed Return,
I received several pages
of links.
For a moment, I
thought the manta
might be faring better
than I'd believed.
But as I began clicking
through, glancing at snapshots,
reading a line or
two, it became clear
that all the reports
were of leaping mobula.
None actually involved
Manta birostris.
Most of the photos,
however, bore
captions that identified the
flying creatures as manta rays.
What was in the process of
happening in Bahia to the word
mantarraya had already happened
on the internet with the term
manta ray.
And this struck me as
a very vivid instance
of the quiet, stepwise
change in our idea of nature.
The name of a huge species had
been bequeathed to a small one.
Alongside some of
the mislabeled photos
of Mobula munkiana were accounts
of nice trips people had taken.
Here are some excerpts.
'It's not easy to reach
but worth the journey,
especially for those who value
unspoiled nature more than
a mint on the pillow.' 'If Baja
is one of North America's last
great wildernesses, then LA
Bay is Baja's crown jewel
of untouched beauty.
Civilization hasn't
changed the place much.'
We go in search of
wilderness, and so it
is wilderness we find.
And we write home about it.
We tell the story of our
rediscovery of nature.
We compose suitably
lyrical prose.
We send back photos, and their
iconography is just right.
We hold up the large
fish we've just caught.
We recline on a
white, sandy beach.
A winged ray leaps
from the water.
These are our dispatches
from the wilderness.
But when those snapshots
are held up against images
from the past,
something is a bit off.
Our fish is rather small.
Or maybe it's not a fish at all
but rather an enormous squid.
That beach is hardly pristine.
In fact, before the
oysters were removed,
it was not a beach at all.
And that ray, it is 2 and
1/2 feet across, not 25.
I, too, am awestruck by
the monstrous squid, lured
by the beach, thrilled
by the leaping ray,
but how can we reconcile
our sincere wonderment
in the face of
what natural worlds
we still have with
our recognition
that what we are seeing
is miserably dilapidated?
On the one hand, a skein
of rays, and on the other,
the likelihood that
they are but fry.
We must be careful, I
think, to hold on to both,
not to let one wash
away the other.
For if we permit ourselves
to indulge too thoroughly
in wonderment, we
will forget where
we are on this long
stairway downward.
But if we let our
sense of history
overwhelm our
wonderment, leaving us
with nothing but blase weariness
of the unimpressive present,
then we won't much
care where we are.
What we must do,
perhaps, is cultivate
our craft of seeing more
than one thing at the time."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AARON HIRSH: Happy to
take any questions.
Greg?
AUDIENCE: Are
there any solutions
to the jellyfish problem
that you could talk about?
AARON HIRSH: Just so you
can hear the question,
are there solutions to
the jellyfish problem?
The jellyfish problem
that he's talking about
is something I've
talked about before.
It's this phenomenon
that, as we fish our way
down the marine food web,
starting with the big fish--
we take out the big fish.
Then we take out
the little fish--
and again and
again, it seems what
replaces those
species are jellyfish.
And it's happened in a number
of different ecosystems.
It happened off the
coast of Namibia,
in the most productive
water in the world.
And it has happened recently
in the Sea of Japan, also
a big fishery, that
the ecosystem is now
dominated by large jellyfish.
Which is a problem
because jellyfish,
although they are
eaten in East Asia,
they don't bring the
same price for fishermen
that the predatory fish do.
Solutions for it-- one thing
that we need to try first
is just to stop
fishing for everything
else, for the large fish,
for a brief period of time.
We haven't been able, even in
fisheries that have collapsed,
to stop altogether to see if
the ecosystem might rebound.
So we don't actually know if
the jellyfish are maintaining
their own stable
place in the ecosystem
by eating the young
of everything else
or if we just leave the
ecosystem alone maybe
everything else will come back
and replace the jellyfish.
So that's the
first thing to try.
There are a lot of managerial
challenges to that, which
I talked about a bit last night,
but that's the first thing.
The second thing, which
would be more radical,
is to actually try to manipulate
the ecosystem actively,
to engage in
biomanipulation, which
would mean to try to fish
the jellyfish intensely
and even possibly to fish, at
the same time-- after we've
let them rebound and seen
that it doesn't work,
if it doesn't
work-- even to fish
at the same time some of
the large predatory fish
to see if you can bring
back the forage fish--
the sardines, the herring, the
anchovy, that kind of thing.
You could try to
manipulate the ecosystem,
but this is a high-stakes
game because it
can go terribly wrong.
Off the coast of Namibia,
there was an attempt
at biomanipulation
to fish anchovies
hard to let sardines
bounce back,
and it backfired terribly.
And we are left with the richest
water in the world now occupied
by jellyfish and bearded gobies
in a stinking hydrogen sulfide
swamp.
So biomanipulation
can backfire badly.
But in places where
we've tried other things
and the stakes are really
high, the potential rewards
are really high, it might
be worth investigating.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: First of all,
thanks for being here,
and those are great readings.
In particular, so we talked a
lot about what's to be mourned
and the downsides.
So I'm wondering, are
there any good results
of these ecosystems being
drastically changed?
Are there any bright lights
or anything to be happy about?
AARON HIRSH: About the
transformed ecosystems?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AARON HIRSH: That's a
really interesting question,
and it presents us with a tough
decision to make as a society.
So yes, there are places where
the transformed ecosystem
can be really
valuable to people.
And the most familiar
one is off the coast
of Eastern Canada,
Nova Scotia, that area.
So you've probably heard
of the collapse of cod.
There are books about cod and
what an incredibly important
fishery it was for
hundred of years.
And then it collapsed once
and for all in the '80s.
That was devastating for a
lot of fishing communities
on the coast of Canada.
But a decade later,
in the absence
of those large, predatory
cod, the populations
of shrimp and crab began
to expand enormously.
And now, the value of the
fishery for shrimp and crab
is greater not just than the
value of the fishery for cod.
It's greater than the
value of the fishery of cod
formerly was at its height.
So now, actually,
that cod are beginning
to come back thanks
to protection,
there's a real dilemma.
Do we manage to let cod back,
or do we manage to keep cod out?
There are many fishermen who
think this would be a bad idea
to reintroduce cod
to the ecosystem.
Something I talked
about last night
was the possibility of
privatizing ecosystems,
essentially turning
the ecosystem over
to local fishermen to give
the local fisherman a chance
to manage it.
In that case, with the
assistance of managers,
the fishermen can decide what
is it that we want to fish for?
What is it that we want to
draw from this ecosystem?
And I think their long-term
interest will probably
serve the ecosystem
well because they
will want to sustain an income
from as many different species
as they can.
If you can have, to some extent,
income from shrimp and income
from cod, you're not only
going to make a lot of money.
You're going to have a
diversified portfolio, which
is appealing for other reasons.
That is, it's not as volatile
as a portfolio consisting
of one stock or one fish stock.
Other questions?
Great, thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]